As you know DPLA is the new kid on the block,
born yesterday, in actual fact,
you could say the inspiration for the DPLA goes back to the founding fathers,
people who are enshrined in the national archives
and Jefferson put it perfectly when he described what he
called the action of the thinking power called an idea as
a process of transmitting light.
He who receives an idea from me receives instruction himself without lessening mine.
As he who lights his taper to candle.
That receives light without darkening. I have to admit, bedevil Kenco to Jefferson.
-- The devil can quote Jefferson
and it is it easy to sound high-minded about to my tenant
and it is difficult to translate abstract principles into reality.
After all, someone had to pay for Jefferson's taper, his candle.
And Jefferson, himself, was not great at business plans.
Especially, when it came to running Monticello. So,
the time has come for action.
Practical action, business plans included.
The DPLA has now reached the stage  where it needs to tap
another American tradition,
they can do no-nonsense pioneering
and pragmatic spirit but also accompanied the founding of
the republic. America was built, in large part,
by entrepreneurs and enterprise was off
and public spirited. Think of Andrew Carnegie.
He used his private wealth to build public libraries across the entire continent,
opening access to knowledge for millions of Americans who
have had very little contact with books.
We need a Carnegie system for the 21st century,
one that will make the cultural heritage of humanity
accessible to everyone. To pay through schools,
to students at community colleges,
to start up experimenters and grudges,
senior citizens and retirement committees,
people everywhere with a love of literature,
a thirst for learning, desire to get ahead, and curiosity about the world surrounding them.
We can do it.
We could make it happen.
In fact, it is already happening and therefore,
we would like to report on a work in progress among the
six groups organized by the DPLA  Secretariat,
with a mission to tackle key issues that must be resolved
if we are to get this library as an running,
at least in a preliminary phase.
18 months from now.
So the first report will come from Peggy, director
and librarian of the Texas State Library and archives commission
or issue a report on the work done
and to be done in the audience and participation registry.
And my cochair Friday
and participation is Carla Hayden at the Pratt public
library. As you can see, the mission statement is still,
our version of the version mission statement is still a work in progress
and this is what we created that had a lively group of
individuals who engaged a rich conversation yesterday that her vision
and mission is to create a digital public Library of
America that is a trusted first platform for knowledge on
line that is universally accessible, participatory,
and compelling for all. And the next slide,
members of the workgroup, and we will keep moving.
Our top priorities,
that was the next thing we refocus our attention on,
and the questions that need to be researched in a TV delved into,
is the cultural relevance of what is in the DPLA .
We want to foster social interaction,
provide a pivot point for people's lives as they are
interacting and intersecting with the DPLA
and that would be universally accessible andd
and what is the killer app is one of the questions that
was asked for a service that is user focused
and that enables collaboration between and among users.
What are the issues around privacy and openness?
They were our dynamic tension they are but we certainly
think we have got to delve into that so that we can
preserve pay to privacy,
something that is important to libraries
and then communication with libraries,
we have to let libraries know,
all the libraries out there, then what DPLA is,
where are we now at this stage?
Our top challenges, what is the DPLA?
We spent a lot of time talking about that we will
continue to do so.  DPLA needs to be the first
or second place that people visit to access information
or use to enable access to information.
It goes beyond that we feel will be lost.
There is a tension between, as we talked about earlier,
the traditional role of libraries in the evolving new
roles of libraries in the Digital age we feel that one of
our top challenges this understanding the voice of the typical user,
not the person who I enjoy a great deal of success but
those individuals who might need to have additional support in order to benefit.
Our work products,
we want a blue print for libraries to libraries can
understand how they interact with the Digital Public Library of America
and how they help their patients interactive talking
points for libraries to bring back to their funders
because that is something that is of great concern,
they don't want the funding for public libraries to
suffer as a result of the unintended consequence of local
government officials thinking than a national digital
public library with additive under local library a longer
break defining audiences based on the services that we
want to provide because those are going to be many.
They also came up with those individuals that we think
need to be added to the conversation among them school librarians, educators,
representatives of the public at large, content creators, authors, publishers,
and you can see some of the service for error case that
we felt were very important for us to focus on as we begin our work on DPLA.
As you can see, these people have been hard at work
and yesterday we had a series of discussions,
I should have explained that,
they are reporting on the results of these workgroups and a workgroups
and the working streams have been expanding
and expanding and certainly public library
and have become key players in defining what the digital
memory of America's great the second workgroup do with
content and scope. Rachel,
who is director of the Digital Library Federation program
will report on it. Soon I felt like content scope, people were saying,
we have to know what is in content scope,
but I think it is one of the things about the work
streams that we are working in parallel it is important
to talk amongst each other as we move forward in some
things we talked about today, inform the conversation in content
and scope those philosophies around open interoperable on
the idea of permanent persistence
and how it relates to building trust in the DPLA as a trusted resource
and working with people who are willing
and able to contribute in a noncompetitive
and collaborative way that was really important,
not only to collections but to build community and the DPLA added a unique value.
So,  to that end, this is our mission statement,
we were wordsmithing sometimes,
but what is behind me is to facilitate the discovery
and exposure of digital heritage content preferment
"access for the enhancement of knowledge and community.
We hope, to this end, the next 18 months,
to content work stream while identifying
and engaging digital content providers
and producers who are willing to participate in DPLA
content building. Who want to leverage
and build interest with people who we see could be
brokers that are content aggregators with the Internet
archive and DCC and -- and we want to foster open
and transparent conversations about collection
development for the DPLA soberly engaged  the public at
large in this conversation of what our valuable
collections to be part of the DPLA.
Who want to encourage digital content creation,
and help facilitate the discovery of more content for the
digital collection. And we see,
what our top three challenges are in we define what we
mean by content and we are including Ms.
and the DPLA and  comparing rules of engagement
and what we think our challenge which is coordinating
other work streams for us
and the next couple of months at top priorities are to
identify content communities a corresponding immunity
advocates to help identify the various for participation was DPLA.
What would be the incentives  to participate in DPLA
and what are the rewards for contribution and DPLA?
And to flesh out the whole idea between the relationships
between persistence and preservation.
Thank you. As you can see,
Rachel has been dealing with these questions for a long
time and is the Digital Library Federation program,
but I said we are the new kid on the block, I meant it,
a lot of people have been working on these issues for a long time
and we are grateful to you for bringing that experience
to us. The third group -- financial
and business information network Street has a lot of work
ahead of anonymity may be curious to know where the money is going to come from.
Kevin Guthrie has some revelations there, I hope
and anyhow, he can tell us what is.
He is president of Ithaca
and has contributed enormously to this whole endeavor.
The revelations may be too strong of a word but for an
eraser we have interdependencies
and we are trying to put together [Indiscernible low audio]
Our mission is simple,
explore mechanisms to generate ongoing support
and thinking about that,
we felt it was important to think about how to
[Indiscernible low audio] regenerate demand for this
enterprise and what it provides
and if we can regenerate that we can generate the current
supply of funds to support it
and a lot of what we were doing in the discussion
[Indiscernible low audio] was identifying the issues we need to address
and as a people thinking about business modeling,
process inputs in order to make certain kinds of
recommendations? The first key areas for the content,
what is going to be in the DPLA
and the second was audience,
those of the two key questions
and those that have web-based resources [Indiscernible low audio],
that is an issue you have to address on the scope of
these enterprises are quite large and that is okay.
At some point, choices will have to be made
and the script and a secondary pieces on the cost side the technical
solutions and governments are going to play a big role in thinking
about helping to determine those.
We know the DPLA is going to represent a diverse
collection of things  that are available
and also there'll be supported by a diverse set of
resources and again, we will meet priorities
and then we talked about was the importance of marketing
and communications and advocacy and by marketing,
we don't mean putting out brochures.
In fact full understanding of what it is value
and be able to communicate effectively
and certain ways we are seeing the benefit of this and great marketing
and a sense of creating awareness of this resource
and the excitement around it as movement that is being
felt in the question is how to institutionalize that movement.
There were some key assumptions that we thought Nader to
make sure their rocksolid before we go forward in the Q1
prudish Keith what was the notion of the DPLA
and the end user
and what your options are for a way to generate funds
and they said that is not the assumption,
tell us now to make adjustments.
The key questions, we try to service questions that would be important for
this community,
for the steering group in terms of setting priorities
and we think that these some bold line distinctions,
will be DPLA  actually holds content?
Will it have content? It is like to have it
or that is a key for the road.
Will the DPLA take in account director some stability for
submissions? We've heard this day
and a variety of ways there's a risk in DPLA says is not
preservation visualizing projects are distributed around
relying on thewithout it being  resourced to check ourselves ability.
The key question is: what is the preservation
responsibilities that DPLA urged a great ,
this has came up again, thinking about audience and funding,
if they can't seriously funded by governments,
and be part of local public library infrastructure,
the thing that we said, the question will be,
what is in it for the kids
and we have to think about that from the standpoint of the audience.
So we raised possible models of heavy things to determine them.
Membership, what would motivate members
and public libraries to become members,
not in a financial way but in terms of supporting the
government funding is a major potential part of this, philanthropic funding,
we did not know about the announcements coming today but
clearly, institutional foundation funding
and other agencies is going to play a role.
As is the opportunity of those questions earlier for individual donations and philanthropic gifts.
Another issue that came up this one, that we thought about was how
there is a lot of structure that exists that maybe is not
being used as much as it was before
or could be purposed with this Presidio model in San
Francisco were some infrastructure is out there that
could be repurposed in terms of physical infrastructure
and services that could be provided.
A really key thing that we talked about at the end,
the devil is in the details on how this works when you
think carefully between time cost
and recurring costs supporting us not to get completely
caught up in the capital but thinking about --
and we thought about the possible work products
and things we could do that would be helpful in some research
and I mentioned the notion of the existing infrastructure
and thinking about what is out there were other places
was among the infrastructure.
It was not about the possibility of the paper the sample
sizes existing research of making information freely
and widely available can support economic growth rate for
thought that free content can actually generate economic
value which is a compelling argument for governments
trying to synthesize the research that is out there
and finally conducting research
and thinking about this question that keeps coming up
about the role of the public library
and one thing that came up as a brainstorm in our group,
if there was an organization and a brand
and a local public library
or historical Society was thinking about digitizing content,
if it were affiliated with a larger national organization,
but that increase the likelihood to make the case locally
for the funding to do digitization and actually,
that could be a compelling way to raise funds and local context
and we thought we might want to conduct research
and having that affiliation -- so that was the range of
things we talked about more questions
and inquiries that answers to have to think about the business model.
Thank you, Kevin. There are a lot of questions
and you probably have a lot of questions so we are now
seeing through these presentations to leave time for your questions as well.
The next presenter is Susan -- the director of the
Institute for the Museum of library services rate she
will report on the discussions of the governance for extreme.
Good afternoon and I'm reporting on behalf of our work street that is
cochaired by John --
and David Faria so we don't have to worry about anything else, they will figure it out.
Our goal is to develop decision-making and management for DPLA
and  what we found in our work yesterday, as Bob said,
there are more questions than answers but the first thing
I would like to say in terms of governance,
is that I am so thrilled to see all of these interested
parties in this room staying until four o'clock on a
Friday afternoon so your planes are late
or you have an hour else to go but I am excited you are
here great to want anybody to think, what went on on Thursday
and what should we know about Thursday?
We have a group of dedicated individuals trying to get
this off the ground to give us a lift but we first want
everyone to know that this is a very open process.
So all of our minutes in activities and notes are public
and if anyone has a particular interest in joining any of these work streams
and I'm sure that we were welcome to do that.
We are just self organizing ourselves and we would welcome your contributions
and your involvement and one of the things we initially talked about was models of organization.
And it is challenging when you don't know what you're
going to be that we did brainstorm models that we thought
we could do further research on think about
and learn from and again I would ask all of you,
if you have suggested models, please share them with us.
We first thought about the obviously relevant models that
we're all familiar with and web organization
and its many different web organizations but we are
particularly interested in the IETF period this is
organization for the qualifications for membership as he
had come to the meetings and Stancil's and voting was done by the loudest --
and it hasn't interesting protocols
and I'm off it will mimic those that we have a enjoyable
time. It is apparently notorious in the web world.
We thought a little bit about libraries
and our group was Maureen Sullivan
and we suggested a LA and she said,
that is going to cause the table quickly
and if there are AOA members in here,
you may be aware of that but it is a model to look at the
thought of not looking at the European model that worked quite well there.
But that is the number of states that we are one big organization.
We are one big country so it is not necessarily parallel
to it to look at public
and private partnerships because ultimately that is what
this enterprise is going to base a bit out there might be
some potentially relevant models for us to consider fruit research networks,
many of us are familiar with in our states in terms of connectivity
and high bandwidth to all of our institutions
and commercial models who want to consider,
scholarly organizations and social movements.
It's interesting that in the sense that we are in the
midst of social movements there may be a synthesis to
come up with that we feel is the best way to manage this
a very ambitious enterprise but the most important thing
for you to know, but we are thinking about it,
we are very open to ideas
and we talked about models for participation which is
going to be a topic that is very much aligned with
financial and business work at developing DPLA.
So we thought that  there could be different models
or levels of participation
and as we said in terms of the content,
there is a basic assumption that there will be content
available to any individual for free we believe that is a
hallmark of this enterprise but with a thick institution
on numbers that would be contributing materials as well
as making materials available for audience and clients
and institutions that contribute materials some of our
major historical societies that have really special
content and all of our federal partners,
they might have a certain level of benefits
and institutions that might want to participate but not necessarily contribute content,
there would be differentiation and also,
in terms of your question about who will hold content, we really think that ultimately,
if we do end up holding content,
we will be a federated system of a number of major nodes
of information around the country
and if we identify an institution is a node of word DPLA, what requirements will be involved,
and what benefits would come from that?
And we are also beginning to think about how institutions
would participate knowing that an individual will be able
to have access to materials for free.
That is not to say that as a collective,
we will not feel our collective energy would allow us to
end up going to extend it license agreement we think that publishing models
and access your public library structure is really a challenging topic
and something that is evolving at the time and we are not,
we think that DPLA might be able to take a role in that
and they certainly don't make any decision about what
might be able to aggregate content so that some of our institutions
or miscible jurisdictions might want to contribute
something to provide access but ultimately there would be
a basic level of material that would be available for free. Facile to have some special levels of institutional
institutions joining us. Federal agencies, state libraries
and other agencies that may not be able to participate
for some reason but we want to have that data available to us.
Again, I'm going to reinforce we believe we are operating on
basic principles of openness and inclusion
and all are welcome as I am sure many of you can go home
and talk to your friends and colleagues and if they are interested in getting involved,
we welcome that, that is exciting. From the governance point of view,
and all further work streams,
we are committed to try to make sure that we get things
done. And by doing that, in order to do that,
we have to ramp up an actual organization in place within
18 months because our wonderful welcome Ms.
at the Berkman Center, we know it launches projects and they go off
and have a life of their own aunt who want to get a life
of our ongoing within 18 months so we might identify
small work streams, workshops, task forces,
we will make the information about those openly available
and anyone can participate that we will be getting things
done some as a sleeve also be doing what it takes to get it done.
One of our big to do in the governance for extreme does develop a standard
and we would like to have a standard that we adopt an if
you live in a state where you like your privacy
or open meeting laws and you know I crackerjack one,
we don't use of city and County of San Francisco,
which can be challenging, having lived through that.
But we will identify flexible form that we think works
for us it really can't be a public statement about our openness and also,
we will enforce norms for participation in all of our
group meetings that everyone has been well behaved today
but will make sure we identify the chair of the meeting,
have agendas, have open mailing list
and also to have a situation where someone is challenging,
deal with them appropriately but in terms of having open meetings,
we certainly want all of our meetings to be open.
That is not necessarily imply an individual who is an
observer in a meeting will have an opportunity to comment.
Not that they wouldn't do that,
but we will have a clear protocol for dealing with
handling our activities. The governance group, I think, really wants to move forward
and we are very excited about opportunities I think all
of us in the workgroups will be working together as best
as we can wear a dedicated in our governance work strain
to have some kind of organization up and running in 18 months.
Thank you, Susan, 18 months is tomorrow.
This is urgent that it is serious, it is for real.
And everyone is invited to participate in the same sure
you have lots of ideas and your point about a movement,
it is well taken, and I sense the energy in this room,
and it was expressed yesterday as well as today it is
symptomatic of a movement is gathering force of please spread the word
and don't hesitate to let the governance committee of DPLA know your thoughts on that subject.
We have other subjects.
Notably, the legal and policy work streams of tears,
Jason Schultz associate director at the Samuelson Law
technology on public policy clinic at the University of
California Berkeley school of Law will report on that.
Jason? Thanks.
We convened the legal law on behalf of the cochair from Columbia
and started to talk about what the legal work streams
roll would play in this process which is a parallel process
and for those that have had a lot of experience working
with innovative experimental emerging technologies in
organizations learned that lawyers probably shouldn't
believe, the best role is to provide support and guidance
and review listening to things that might need input but
to be supporting a playing a strategic role to make sure
everything goes smoothly but not to get in the way of anything.
So she will see from the mission statement to try to portray the philosophy
and to think about our role in terms of helping the DPLA
balance and a legal risks that are perceived , building a collection
and enabling experiments in progress and access to those of the two things that I would focus
on terms of our conversations,
thinking about the limbless collection of providing broad
access and experiments. In terms about,
the three main things we decided to focus on,
helping to establish best practices guidelines of things,
and people want to deal with the particular situation
and we can provide some of that in terms of investigating
emerging problems many of you might know about orphan works
and you want to make it accessible that is a problem that
has been emerging for a while
and in terms of identifying the common policy issues
and what the solutions are an then there is an option to
organize some workshops over the next 18 months
and we are wanting to organize around a partner with
other work streams to identify with some of those could
be and some of our thoughts were, access,
a lot of discussion around the best way to provide access
especially the visually impaired people, issues around digital lindane
and the best practices they are. In terms of acquisition, and also looking at licensing options,
especially other open licensing
and privacy which has come up a couple of times is an
area where policies can play an important role so some of the things that came up for us we are looking to play a
supportive role with issues arising are the places we can be strategically helpful,
Thank you. Jason,
you can see everything is connected with everything so
that is what the difficulties in getting organized
because legal issues are connected with content which is connected with finance
and he did a heroic job of sorting through some of the legal issues
and we are counting on top of the future but meanwhile,
last of the technical work streams was indeed technical
and the associate director of the Smithsonian Institution
and Martin is great that they might be Hannity PLF
or so we are grateful for that
and pass it on to your boss but meanwhile,
can you tell us what is going on here?
I want to thank the technical group is a good group of
people that we can together very well
and -- at the Missouri botanical Garden
and the technical group is going last telling me to do is build on --
and I think the technical group does its work well, you are invisible to the eventual product,
and detailing or better yet,
it will appear as magic so what we have to do is become invisible and appear as magic
and for the rest of the DPLA.
Some of the challenges we noted, we need to achieve that magic to clarify technical
deliverables of DPLA.
We need to figure out this key technical things are that
we need to create in a technical environment and the second one is,
the one via collaborative development team?
In addition to the work done correctly, products that are out there,
ready to cooperate to create whatever the DPLA product
will be great to the sink, we need to provide input to the rest of the work streams
in terms of feasibility.
It is important to have great ideas at the same time,
technically feasible at the same time so those are the
challenges and in terms of those to Liverpool's,
that a number of thoughts in mind of one of the things was,
Susan mentioned me to have a killer apps with it is to be
a killer ASP that appears within an environment one thing
that we think will be interoperability
and openness to think that is a key thing we need to do
is have all this data available so people can build their
own shiny things on top and at the same time,
building a shiny thing that can deliver within her 18 month timeframe. The thing is,
which have plenty of open systems
and services that enable other people to build their own
localized use of this content such as pushing it out to
local libraries and historical societies and Museum
and integrate it with their own content for their own
local community spirit whatever short-term deliverables,
we will to do a more thorough analysis of the Sprint
competitors so we can see what is out there
and what parts are best used
and how to integrate all that work into products?
We also want this to be a very participatory experience
and are interested in work streams
and we want to develop the code is openly and visible as possible.
We will be openly deposited some of the primary sources
and we're thinking about Google code etc. and appropriate places where code can be watched as it
gets developed another thing is,
as they deliverables want to make sure that our public participation enables the use
and reuse of metadata objects collections
and code within DPLA whatever goes into DPLA should come out of DPLA
and be reused whenever system serviced around there.
The other key thing that we looked at with some of the related projects
and we don't reinvent the wheel but other projects are
out there that we can use and ideas and code and again,
looking at large-scale models, you have Flickr,
in terms of public participation in creating content
and YouTube am standing examples that come out of the Internet archive and an environment,
there's also a personal library to a citation praises him -- that was mentioned today
and tools that we will label on top can be used in
different ways and also collections, registration, repository,
and how those can inform the development here in Missoula
to ignore the commercial side of the world.
With examples through the network. Development, things like Amazon,
how's the delivering content is also systems that are
done by interesting commercial services, Netflix, sci-fi,
overdrive, iTunes, you and the big indexing services and other digital libraries,
I think you're a busy key model the Wikipedia community, freebase, OCLC
and some of the other types of services so we are hoping to work within the community
and build on what we get from the rest of the work streams to do that.
And Marquis in the first goal should be to have a joint
meeting with the content legal group to see what the
parameters are going to be where the initial bills.
Thank you very everyone has kept to the time limits
and that means we have a good 15 minutes left for discussion
and hope you're not feeling exhausted but the energy
level is very high and then you have at least a glimpse,
a preliminary glimpse of this kind of organization kinds of financing and technological support
and so on will constitute DPLA.
So,  please ask questions
and I can't see that if someone can put their hands
visibly off, we can get things started.
There is a hand in the very back.
Maybe a microphone is on the way.
If you were to justify yourselves.
-- Gomez. The question has to do with messages,
and part of the picture frame, in my mind,
we are in Washington DC and I'm curious.
Is there some outreach or messages being floated over with some legislators here
about this project and the need for some support?
All of us have congressional delegates back home
and I know it might be premature but I can't imagine
there is not some discussion about this at some level,
what is the thinking behind getting some engagement with
the congressional leadership about this project? Did --
A very good question that has been haunting a lot of
people. Can anyone answer it?
I am tempted to ask some of the locals such as the Susan,
it is not as if you are a congresswoman is that you
occasionally cross path with this other race. What do you think the prospects are?
We spend a lot of time talking about this yesterday as well
and I think we all want to get a good assessment of how
the meeting went today. And then, I know that the people at the Berkman Center are going to
be developing some press releases and getting some information out.
In terms of talking with our elected officials
and other also love it if David would chime in as well.
This is an absolutely wild time in DC.
And we have a super committee that is working to get the
big budget deal done by the end of November and the agencies are working on resolutions
and we don't have budgets
and we hear they will be done by November and is really chaotic.
It is not to say it is not a good time,
I don't know that they would hear bunch with all that
noise but I do think that it is something that steering committee level,
we need to develop a plan for what we want to make
legislators aware this is going on there are some
legislators that are interested in digital information
and aware that it has a big impact on our communities
and trying to identify some that we know will be very familiar
and supportive of our general efforts of her not doing
any kind of funding. But,
I would like David to chime in and also,
John said he wasn't going to talk that maybe Bob has some
ideas. David, do you have any thoughts on that?
There is a lot of interest on the hill under the White House on this
and for those of you who have not read the president --
at the end of December signing a digital future, a $3 billion initiative,
there are places for us in that initiative.
The hill is interested in anything related K-12 so when I
have been talking about this, with my contacts, Hill,
I have been teaching it in terms of its value to the K-12 community.
I was invited to Hartford of the last three weeks by
Congressman John Larson has a former history teacher to
talk about our products to Grupo superintendents
and teachers from the Hartford Connecticut area
and we talked about the digital public library to keep
their eyes on that is another source. In my own context,
I have been planting seeds that this is something to pay attention to.
The very first ever house caucus of the national archives
has been formed were having our first meeting on the hill
sometimes the end of November
and something I'm going to be talking about with members
of the House caucus. There a lot of opportunities.
Thank you, David, he will put in a good word for DPLA.
Among the lawyers and people interested in the law,
but has a lot of discussion about possibly an attempt to
pass more than book legislation
and before the next question comes out of my chest Jason,
what do you think of this?
Should we be writing to her congressman saying,
nevermind about the budget crisis, barbarous --
or from books really count.
I feel that the answer has been laid out before me.
I think dealing with orphan work works defined in many
ways, they are not commercially viable, out-of-print,
hard-to-find, different ways to look at that issue and the thing is,
there is a desire some time to have a one-stop shop
solution that I think there are solutions that people are
dealing with these different sets of collections in ways
which they are able to move forward with the law allows
him to that of various doctorates
and think that we want to explore the strategies
and if it gets to the point where
and make sense to think about trying to push for a change
I think that is something that has to be considered a given name comments made,
he don't necessarily want to go there until you have to
enter a lot of places they go first for you considered
those so it is not that it is off the table but we have a
lot of innovative and creative places to go and I think the law supports that.
Other questions? I am sure you have plenty.
I hesitate to speak on communication since the last
conversation that my sense is the conversation on
communication is top down, policy down,
the higher end abuse issues in terms of communications
people involved in decision-making
and policies I think there is still a need for us to look
at, if you will, the Reader's Digest reader
and bring an action of what DPLA is that what it could
mean to those people  who are not thinkingg of the level
of planning a K-12 course
or an academic exercise are doing research of one form
or another but look to what we provide in terms of a
learning environment and on-the-fly learning,
on-demand learning, or just in general,
entertainment in one form or another,
it still can be entertaining
and we have to look at the bottom,
a very horrible phrase, multiple facets, top and bottom,
we have to do the whole gamut.
So one consideration is to work communication set of
problems into the actual discussion that will be going on the various work streams
and I think we have to find a way to do that
and certainly, with the kind of user in mind the develop,
that you mentioned, the ordinary reader,
certainly not the college professors put the kind of
person who is curious about the world surrounding him
or her and people who want to have fun
and go beyond entertaining and books and reading
and looking at items and who want to build that and in my opinion.
And who will take that very seriously as they go to the
next streams. Thank you. I saw a hand over here.
I am a student at -- college.
My issue is one of ideology rather than logistics.
They're talking about openness and access and social movements
and I'm getting my library science degree
and my public history degree
and I have dismayed that DPLA  is choosing to invoke the
name of Andrew Carnegie as an ideological foundation.
Because while some may know him as a benefactor of libraries,
the reason that he funded a the Homestead library was
because of the public up for him
and his direct involvement of the murder of workers in
his own null and this might seem nitpicky,
but as the DPLA continues
and then they will be working with public historians
and institutions on cultural heritage institutions I
don't think that this will be the first time that this
was brought up because coming from a public history
aside, Andrew Carnegie is a hot topic
and people love to talk about him and taken apart
and so I want to put that out there.
I think that is really important but I will say that
whenever I talk about Carnegie
and his role on the libraries I focus on not on him
and what his motivation was because I think that there
are some really problematic areas you look at the
fullness of his motivation. But to think about his role in partnering with local
communities, because what he did,
he built libraries but only on the condition of that
community would continue to support that library with
sustainability so when I talk about Carnegie in public
libraries, that is what I focus on
and I don't think anyone here would want to focus on any
other aspect, I think what Bob was referring to was to meet someone
else who is going to have that same vision of partnership
if they can help us build it,
and those of us in this room are going to have to help
all of our respective groups and institutions
and individuals that we represent views that resource to
the fullest. I don't know if that helps any.
The question about his motivation
and the last conversation about a message,
not that we necessarily want to overstate that when you think about libraries
and think about knowledge in this country, the name,
Carnegie, whatever that story might be,
is emblematic of that and this lady said,
we know he did a lot
and communities to ensure they would have sustainable
facilities for like it or not, it is iconic
and when you talk about libraries with the general public,
and Carnegie raises this recollection of their building
and who want to get away from that.
I personally talked about Bill Gates as a 21st century
Andrew Carnegie which I think he has done a should not
say that in front of -- who has done so much for this
effort but I think that when we think about messaging,
what to think about that but we also need to be aware of
iconic images that can have an impact with our generic
user that we are talking about.
Our Reader's Digest person who is going to be excited by
DPLA because of their easy access to amazing information and a lot of it can be local.
I am excited to have the can provide a platform for local
information is so exciting to people around the country,
it is probably never going to be mounted anywhere,
but it is so unique and important,
and can rally community for their pride
and interest in what is unique in seeing that,
I think that is a great step forward but I think the messaging is critical
and I do appreciate your sensitivity of that.
I'm glad you raised the point
and I actually did not hesitate before invoking the name of Carnegie as well as Jefferson.
There were parts of Jefferson's past but in my view,
one of the things that makes this country distinct,
this private foundations who work for the public good.
The DPLA is going to  defend at least for its launch,
getting started, and private foundations
and then founded by the Rockefellers, Carnegie's, and so on
and so I feel that we are different from Europeans
and the Europeans depend on the state,
they don't have a philanthropic tradition that is in any
way comparable so we might as well be open about it
and maybe we should not run the Carnegie flag up the
flagpole too high but the Carnegie foundation as a
foundation that I hope will support the DPLA.
We need this kind of debate so thank you for making a point.
I am from the free Library of Philadelphia
and I have a list ago question.
I think this covers all of your groups,
do you see any conflict with institutions, especially public libraries,
continuing to use digitally created items
and images for revenue-generating services for the libraries?
Are we to expect everything to be put out there was a complete open license?
In Texas, we have rules regarding public libraries
and if they want to be accredited,
what they can charge for
and expect them to make everything that is available in the library whether digital or poor loan
and a physical format,
or available for free in every state will have a
different law or regulation but in our state,
that is the latest entry
Want to make one comment, I think that is a good point,
that this young lady made great
and I think it bears further research
and discussion because as we were sitting here discussing these topics,
I know that breast since I have worked at the San Francisco public Library
and the Seattle public Library in many cases,
photographs are being made available for commercial purposes, the library
or the friends are foundation get a fee for that so those
are the kind of details that we are going to have to work
out for those important question that we have to deal with.
There is a lot of research done about this sharing data
and images and we're talking about content and scope,
what does it mean when you contribute,
a contributing objects?
Are you contributing data?
There's a lot of information about that's the one thing that makes it very exciting,
but you deposit our brain to it,
should be opened for reuse for anybody whether it is commercial or not
and so is the libraries to want to commercialize their images and give them to the DPLA,
I think having the freedom to do that in the space to do
that is a good thing to consider for the DPLA.
I have to look at my watch, I know there are probably many discussions but David
Ferriero has something to say
and we have some things to say about David Ferriero which
are mainly, thank you.  We really appreciate it.
[Applause]
The floor is yours
and there may be some other questions as well. The
Thank you, Bob.
I think we have come to the moment of gleeful rendezvous.
The next time we should have wine with this crowd.
And you have all become official DPLA groupies by your
attendees and your  a part of a new social movement
and has been an honor to have you occupying my house today.
A couple of high points for me today for the
announcements from the collaboration with us
and we are not of that we have a collaboration
and especially listed in the migration exhibit is coming
just because of my own history since I've discovered
about how my grandparents got into the country
and wonderful gifts from Sloan and Arcadia,
thank you very much for your support.
[Applause] The
And David Weinberger's comment about having his head
and heart exploding a to interoperate,
is a wonderful take away for today.
You still here?
Yes. Where? David has a new book coming out.
When is it coming out? The middle of December.
And for those of you who are worried about information
overload, forget it,
Davis went to share some insights with you.
You heard multiple versions of DPLA which is what is so
exciting about today,
this is very much a work in progress
and invitation for you to contribute in one of the nicest
things I heard today was the use of DPLA as a verb.
You can DPLA it. That is major and a lightning round
and exciting glimpses of
and the ability to move quickly and as Bob said,
18 months is not very far away
and the metaphor of reservoirs and bridges, and Bob said,
we can do it. So let's do it. Thank you for being here.
[Applause]